breaking news for you this morning a
suspect has been arrested in a string of
shootings targeting homeless men in new
york city and washington d.c
authorities released new photos of the
man that they were looking for yesterday
he is suspected of killing two homeless
men and wounding three others during the
past two weeks nancy chen is at the
scene of one of the shootings here in
new york city you know nancy yesterday
mayor adams said somebody knows this guy
please come forward i was hoping once
the pictures were released there would
be a quick arrest that seems to be the
case what can you tell us about this
person
gail good morning to you police in
washington d.c confirm it happened just
hours ago and officers with the atf
washington field division they arrested
the suspect as he was walking around the
city and this comes after authorities
released new images and information just
yesterday we do want to warn you that
some of the images we're about to show
you are disturbing authorities released
this video on monday with the hopes that
someone would recognize the suspect
upping the reward to a total of 70
thousand dollars two homeless men were
shot in new york city over the weekend
including this man killed as he slept
captured on surveillance video on monday
police in d.c handed out flyers an
encampment for homeless people three men
were shot in the area earlier this month
one of them died authorities say all
these shootings appear to be related and
premeditated occurring in the early
morning hours usually while the victims
were alone and forensics experts have
also confirmed the same gun was used in
all the shootings d.c police say the
suspect is now being
interviewed in their homicide branch
that more information will be coming out
tony
hope they do indeed have the guy nancy
thank you very much